we've been spying on your team for a
number of months searching for a mole so
this whole thing was a setup man
something like that and you suspect me
well as you've said
you're the only one left alive but if I
did set this all up why would I go visit
my boss should I be running away or
chillin in the Bahamas or something I
can understand you're very perplexed
Kittridge you've never seen me very
perplexed no but I can see your nose
hairs yeah hey seriously Karl we're
close enough
yeah it's Emmett ography now is
rhinoplasty oh thank you enough of this
we think you've got it all figured out
well you're wrong for I'm really
huh my god mr. Phelps but you're like
the hero of the series you murdered my
team and Cole plotted quite the twist
hey you could not really it's just me
let this mean there's me evil to me
Cameron Oh
what are you doing here deterring you
and those are protecting that the
default but I can be elected Queen in a
galaxy far far away I'll be ridiculous
nobody likes Queens well great is there
anyone else who wants to betray me
what's up girlfriend
Oprah how could you after I gave you
such ratings by making an ass of myself
on your show my networks going down the
toilet and I need the money
the queen of Dayton Tucker's betrayed
you what are you going to do next you
know this is getting so silly I'll tell
you exactly what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
call director Brad Bird he's bluffing
hey Brad yeah how you doing look we
really need you to come over and direct
a mission impossible I don't care if
you're directing ratatouille - Oh rabbit
- we the two is just in the middle I
gather anyway we really need you down
there to direct a Mission Impossible
well don't argue with me there's a hot
tub filled with million-dollar bills
with your name on it see an event the
Iron Giant that's all
destroy very great
what now Ethan now later giant we
destroy cars climb the world's tallest
building welcoming us with your very
eyes and if we have time al Qaeda
zombies
so how do we do not well since we
release mission improbable online we
only got a few 128 views and the only
guy who gave it a thumbs up got down
voted 158 thousand times I could get
downloaded 150 thousand times but only
has 128 views doesn't matter well what
the guy who liked it say dude I am so
stoned at least we have a demographic
stoners hey don't judge man you know
we've all in a box of cinnamon toast
crunch and asked our feet for financial
advice we're getting off track they said
it was more confusing than the Brian
DePalma bill I mean more confusing
because we made something that's too
smart for the general public or they're
still trying to figure out what that it
can space monkeys have to do with
finding the NOC list
well Colonel really enjoyed the digit
caramel you did kill the Frenchman and I
like that maybe we'd go too far that's
why I proposed a different plan ladies
gentlemen Cajun I propose that we
returned back to our race curling
ourselves to sleep something bold
something simple something that says
America but is nevertheless dumb down to
appeal to our demographic of stupid
idiotic pot-smoking youtubers talking
through Michael Bay well that is the
dumbest America has to offer I'll give
you that
and that just Michael Bay transformers
Michael Bay transformers really what
better way to an overgrown manchild in
through his toys Donnie you are an
overgrown manchild
it's why I'm perfect to direct okay
transformers it is yes Carl I want you
to find the nearest toy store and start
looking through the dumpster we have a
film to make behold
Optimus Prime has arrived
pajamas oh my god before time began
there was the cube
which we will confusingly called the
Ostmark at certain times it has the
ability to create life some wanted it
for good others for bad and here on
planet Cybertron which is very metal as
you can see the ultimate battle will
take place all seems well thank the
maker that we machines have no emotions
desires or concepts of evil mr. oh shut
up back there make a draw why because
I'm evil what that's it
yes well here I thought someone who
calls himself a Decepticon will be a
little more trustworthy I guess some
robots were just for the hole in my
heart but somebody didn't want to give
me character motivation Decepticon stick
to the script Tacoma city wrote the
making Fox character as a smart badass
girl with dreams of joining the CIA as a
weapon specialist yeah and you crossed
that out and changed it to whore I'm
just trying to keep it real to Michael
Bay's portrayal of women now you want me
to go against it that's fine I hear you
go I will update that for you there slut
there's only so many rewrites I can do
you know I I think that one turns into a
boat
really
it's real professional so there it is
there's a robot man in the Antarctic my
grandfather was crazy I'm selling his
glasses on eBay
my parents are a bunch of freaks the
jocks will hate me my last name in
English means the beef but by the end of
film I will somehow save the universe
and beg the hottest cheap working in
Hollywood congratulations you've passed
expedition 101 all right this would go
great with my a in Iraq yelling now that
we've gotten those platforms on the way
how about some sex oh man no my car is
broken down if only there was some super
sexy jailbait who doesn't really have
much of a personality because our
preteen lowest-common-denominator
audience doesn't really like that sort
of thing in us it'll get us more views
and fast more money along super sexy
jailbait she's probably just changing
into a bikini oh you did a nude scene in
a one-woman Titanic show how is this
very different hey that was tasteful I
was making love to myself for myself not
some horny teenagers I mean come on look
at this thing what are you a porno actor
Michael Bay was you will take me
seriously if I wanted to do porno again
I would go do a porno again - come on
guys having a little bit of a diva
moment I need you to go in there with
your sensitive ways you calm her down
hmm
all right what do you need me to say
just try to emphasize that my scene is
so much better for her because she's
more experienced at it be sure to put it
in quotes cuz I'm sure they'll emphasize
how serious you are okay man you on it
so how'd it go
all right all right all right we'll do
your way we'll do it old school will do
it smart but we still get me a body
double where are we gonna find a body
double soon mine oh sure I mean like
fixing cars and the rainy mud pits of
the California spring break there's more
to me than that
my father always wanted a boy but he
died on a mission in North Korea since
then I decided to dedicate my life to
avenging his death I may act like a
tomboy but I'm also a woman with
feelings of longing and regret I'm more
than just an object I'm a human being
Wow I truly listen to most of that
actually kind of liked it hmm oh look he
just went inside chased outfits and they
came out back here again yeah actually
started to dig that hole respecting your
thing okay so you know how I got these
Transformer toys so that we can show
them transform me you know I actually
have something physical that turns into
a car or something like that
oh well I came across a bit of a snag so
these don't transform other transformers
yes you see the problem you're smart
Oh what do the instructions say have fun
I don't think they're meant to transform
it transforms into a cripple that was
dark
there's not even a picture of a car on
here I mean look at it it's just the
robot what does it transform it to a
choking hazard maybe if you lay them
flat yeah like you can still take you
places so your guys's idea right now is
to lay him down flat yeah you are high
wait wait this is a horny perverted toy
transformer porn you know what that
probably exists but we're getting off
sup I start in it
seeing huh me of crash-landed on this
planet we must now disguise ourselves so
that nobody will find us suspicious
tobots
transform yes my Autobots you are
transformed into corpses that way if the
enemy walks by you they will think you
are dead but won't they be surprised
when they find you are not dead isn't
that exciting
sir we've just been Pearl Harbor the
director of Pearl Harbor
plastic shiny made in China with
accessory repeat with accessories damn
it launch all vessels at Toys R Us we
gotta keep this thing airtight
Tacoma I think I just had a moment of
Zen
you know boom Oni I think he means
Satori but what is it isn't it weird how
aliens always attack Americans I mean
the world is huge isn't it how do they
always find us well if you take them to
account all of our Wars and our bases
and stuff it's kind of actually
impossible to not hit us it's kind of a
commentary on the kinds of being a
military superpower Wow
Donny said that no you said that no one
would give a crap if they hit Bangladesh
where's that yeah now that we are
transformed we must stop the Decepticons
we need a hero to aid us in our quest
you you look like a strong fellow I am
Optimus Prime the transformer
well I'm SIA the beef have you done
anything legendary I was uneven Stevens
do you have any special skills yes I
have the ability to destroy an entire
Spielberg franchise with my mere
presence Wow
now that's power you will eat us on our
quest though we are gigantic
transformers the size of tall buildings
we still need the help of
pay no attention to that gigantic car
the one that almost seats the size of me
in fact actually that's one of the
Transformers good for you guys I knew
you get it down eventually you get a
gold star golly gee Here I am in my
everyday teenage room with Jurassic Park
posters I'm eccentric ooh and my parents
are coming at Gigi's son it's time for
an awkward comedic family interlude to
break up Molly's explosion bottle bus
five five why not four as I said before
we Autobots are masters of disguise is
mine can be a timing coincided with a
series of ham-handed the place
predictable GOG oh geez your mother's
here don't make her say masturbation
information she set aside we're coming
in Autobots transform okay come in mom
and dad that was close son young will
stop being endearing in that goofy 70
show sort of way yeah yeah yeah well how
do I know if this isn't like greetings
parental units of the beef I am a wham
it works yeah it's a special kind of
lamb from Japan it's also an alarm clock
beep beep all right son I believe you
for reasons of plot contrivance come on
honey let's go for your information he
keeps his marijuana in there all right
let's go the truth lamps don't lie no
the marijuana is mine one of the great
things about having Carl is that he's
not only a great cameraman but he's also
a great chef which works great cuz I
still only had to pay him from one job
yeah so much like the military it may
not to be pretty
yeah what happens if an accent I don't
know you just said but I'm pretty sure
the pigs not gonna like it
nonsense I'm going to keep his life how
people spend their entire lives trying
to find me fear death
no moans him for he goes to secure with
meat horn and Valhalla there he will
feast from the contents profit vote on
it is as a piggy brethren to celebrate
this fact he must eat his flesh first we
start by removing the organs what's the
matter too much rectum no it's a script
I'm kind of concerned about these twins
skids and mudflap yeah what about them
do you have yeah how insensitive this
crap is I mean they make Jar Jar Binks
look like Frederick Douglas well how do
you think I feel you yeah I mean do you
have any idea how racially insensitive
Shia LaBeouf is to white people I bet
you never even considered that before
did you I mean really think about it
that's white guy sure we've had it
pretty good but we can't jump it we can
trap the only sport that we have is
hockey and badminton we can't take our
shirts off without looking like shape
cats
we're revolting creatures do you have
any idea what it's like to be the exact
definition of uncool and for someone
like this Republican haircut work to
come along and say I am white people
hear me squeak and complain if he was
any whiter he'd be Woody Allen's
mayonnaise is that what we are to you is
that what we are to the rest of the
world just a bunch of beluga skin
buffoons yeah
yeah you are today we're doing the cname
weak yeah so we gotta get this thing
rolling before we end up zip and ease up
on this crazy transformers yeah yeah you
take a piss almighty little and how you
know settle this thing right here I'm
gonna grab me a snack of KFC and great
so I quit what did you think they were
going to say come jazz let's help our
brothers and racial oppression hey
optimus
why don't the white Cadillacs and the
black Cadillacs go and have a beer
together
these are simple salt-of-the-earth
filmmakers
Hollywood executives Michael Bay you
know morons I'm just trying to mock the
idiots of the world by pandering to them
and possibly making a profit is that so
wrong
fine I won't blame you just your entire
race and the people who funded this
plastic Birth of a Nation I appreciate
that
we're still not doing it fair enough I
just have to nix the robot minstrel show
let's wrap this thing up Michael Bay
style you scurry around like a panicky
chipmunk you stand there and look sexy
you start firing randomly while shouting
meanwhile we will hit each other like
Rock'em Sock'em robots
that bombastic music I can still hear my
soul
Oh
- Jesus are they still going there like
12 hours no no it's going to 40 minutes
it just feels like 12 hours have to do
something the audience is gonna have to
pee
ha I've knocked you up for the 14th time
Megatron and I just got back up again
how long I'm gonna be able to go on like
this
fortunately our batteries have a
half-life of 9 million years that's my
crazy grandfather's glasses apparently
he claimed he saw an iron band at the
Antarctic and what do these clothes
their saris a little button up there
beyond your giant destroyed ship and
this thing
the audience is starting to eat their
popcorn boxes
now we remain plotting it
this letter has arrived for you it's
been altered it has been please screen
for security reasons oh it's a letter to
my brother but it's been returned with
no forwarding address
I guess he moved again such as
unfortunate yeah what about you Carl get
me family before the fall film I had a
family then what has evolved from but
that's a good thing not to fear standing
right under it you see my friend there
are two historical hunters that all
Europeans make the first is never start
a land war in Asia
the second is never underestimate the
destructive power of kinetic Communist
engineers what about you coin any family
I'm Irish you can have any one of my 600
relatives and so our journey comes to an
end we didn't plan on landing here but
the only other planet in our system was
Omicron 12 and the inhabitants of that
world should poop out their noses and
that's just too weird for me so for now
we are here smug and satisfied that this
is as good as against but Optimus aren't
there more adventures in store for us
listen kid I'll spare you the time you
go nuts I die there's a three-hour
battle in the desert I come back
Megatron dies he comes back we become
America's bitch you switch girlfriends
there's some crap in the moon followed
by a four-hour battle
still interested so the story goes that
there's this film called be warned fast
forward um be kind rewind I think anyway
led to all these youtubers remaking
movies at their own only they call them
Swedes or Swedish films or something
like that I don't even get it I mean
it's like sweets I mean what the hell is
a sweet we get down to it anyway
I don't even touch that they're in
removed exactly I mean they're going
around acting like their stuff is so
much better but did you see that Karate
Kid one I mean it's like when they're
trying to simulate the ocean and the
beach like they did the cardboard
cutouts and they color that blue and
stuff like that we have green screens we
are a hundred percent closer to being
George Lucas than they will ever be I
mean I just assumed that's what we were
doing it's a pretty popular movement
most people get their start on the
internet hell the Cartoon Network can
give a show to an orange I mean there's
got to be hope for us I mean we get down
to it it does really matter what had the
sweets ever given us that's Swedish Chef
and the girl the Dragon Tattoo so you're
not intimidated okay that rape scene
from the girl in the Dragon Tattoo that
edge it was a little intense but that's
never stopped me before we are just
gonna go along business as usual and
nothing is going to stop us
so my metal friend why are you writing
letters what did you do if I must've
apologize so what will you do if save
them to take you back
hey girl you to the camera I think what
sit down in my office